a key focus for tonight has been
demonstrating why PlayStation delivers
the best place to play today and in the
future you've seen that in the diverse
portfolio of games coming from our
worldwide studios and our close partners
and we're also bringing this to life in
new ways with hardware when we design
ps4 we made a conscious decision to
making the most powerful gaming console
ever created and surround it with
breakthrough games features network
capabilities and peripherals
that together would redefine next-gen
gaming a key peripheral that we've
offered to ps4 gamers since launch as a
choice is the PlayStation camera
we believe that the playstation camera
would be a popular option because of the
value it provides for more immersive
gaming but the response has far exceeded
our expectations and we're enhancing the
value of the playstation camera what it
brings to ps4 by pursuing new innovative
technology that takes gaming to an
entirely new dimension at GDC in March
we unveiled project Morpheus which
demonstrates how we are fully leveraging
the power of the PlayStation camera the
response from the development community
and gamers was phenomenal all of your
voices have been heard and today there
are creative teams around the world
working with us to define the future of
gaming and entertainment we have project
Morpheus in our booth at e3 this year
with two new demos so I encourage all of
you to stop by and try it
you